hi everyone my name is Tamra chambers
and I have a ring pop because my blood
Sugar's low it's watermelon I think I
can't actually tell the flavor just bad
it just tastes like weird it honestly
doesn't it honestly does not have a
flavor so this is definitely why
everyone clicked on this video tonight I
saw bad times at the El Royale it
doesn't happen very often but every once
in a while there is a film that just
comes in under everyone's radar and it's
just so good and it's just not talked
about and you're like what's going on
here am I crazy or was that one of the
best films I've ever seen why isn't
everyone talking about this why haven't
I heard everything about this film why
am I looking at a fake watch on my wrist
those are the questions we ask ourselves
this is that film this film though is so
good that I can't even call it a movie I
keep calling it a film that's when you
know when Tamra starts getting
pretentious that's when you know this
movie was so so so so so outrageously
beautiful that somebody like me who is
it I mean I don't know I've seen a lot
of films now and I know that I'm
technically a movie reviewer I guess if
you even want to call it that but I'm
dumb when it comes to like movies I
didn't grow up watching them but you see
this and even a dumb dumb like myself
knows that it's stunning it's beautiful
and like excitingly so like you watch it
and you're excited and every shot that
comes up you're like what I wouldn't
even call this like that immersive of a
story or like that even like brilliant
or out of this world of a story the
characters were just written so fucking
well that you're like in it to win it
you're in it to win it in it to win it I
shit what is that from that High School
Musical Jesus Christ Tamara this cash
was incredible there's two breakout
stars I would say that I've not seen in
anything else I think they were out of
this world but one thing that I really
need to address so in my earlier days of
making these reaction videos Tamara's
Timbers never seen I think it was on is
I mixed up Jeff Bridges and Kurt Russell
I don't know what I'm doing I was like I
don't really like Kurt Russell and I was
talking about Jeff Bridges and Jeff
Bridges wasn't in escape to New York I
understand the levels of dumbness that
goes into that I think I've only ever
seen Jeff Bridges as the dude and to be
very honest with all of you I've not
even seen the great Lebowski all the way
through ever I've seen like bits and
pieces of it and I just felt like I
couldn't do it as a tamra's never seen
because I had seen a little bit of it
not even seeing him fully in that and
then I saw him like a year back hell or
high water in 2016 I was watching all
the oscar-nominated films and I wasn't a
fan of that movie and so I think I just
lumped him into this like Oh old like
crotchety man kind of thing and by god
what I was I was never so happy to be so
wrong while watching a movie he was so
cute in this movie you guys I was like
giggling and like these parts that are
very serious and he's like crying and
burying a solar I'm just giggling cuz
he's so good in these parts and it just
blew me away in my notes one of the last
things I wrote is amazing acting Jeff
period sorry
period Cynthia areevo I've never seen
her in anything before at least I don't
think that I have she was phenomenal
any time her and Jeff Bridges were in a
scene together it was just music it was
just pure magic symphony of incredible
acting on screen they were just
beautiful together I I'm so pumped up
right now I've so much adrenaline in my
soul for these trips they did such a
good job and I just I'm blown away that
it's not being talked about more I saw
this trailer two times before seeing it
tonight and that's crazy because I see
at least one movie a week for Tamra just
off of the show and so I end up seeing a
lot of trailers a lot of times and this
one I saw twice it was an incredible
trailer I thought it was really
beautifully done I was a little upset
that it gave too much away and then
watching the movie it didn't give too
much away at all in a beautiful
beautiful play it's an incredible
trailer now looking back on it knowing
what it gives away in what it doesn't I
have heard no one talked about this I've
seen no reviews online before going into
the film I was like it's anyone even
gonna watch this if I make an episode of
it so I looked up a written review on
like IGN or something I completely
disagree with the author of this article
they were like oh they misuse time a bit
and it's really pretty and we think it's
great but like there's a lot of like
misuse timing like you could have cut
out like 20 minutes I super disagree I
think it was all used really well I saw
the run times two hours or 20 minutes
and was like all right it's kind of what
I just spent the last Saturday watching
all eight of the Texas Chainsaw Massacre
movies and all of those are like 90
minutes which is great now sitting down
for a two hour and 20 minute movie I'm
like oh yeah a little spoiled I'm a
little spoiled with run time but every
single moment was super captivating and
not even like high stakes adrenaline
just beautiful beautifully done if this
doesn't get nominated for cinematography
then I quit I quit this Ring Pop
soundtrack is amazing it's absolutely
incredible how they use sound in this
mostly coming from our lead that I've
already spoken about a lot she is a
vocalist she's a singer and oh my god
she's so good and her acting and her
subtle facial expressions while she's
singing in these really intense moments
and it just accentuates what's happening
it's so well done the great thing about
the hotel it's a seedy place right
outside of Reno
and it's right on the line of California
and Nevada and it's so much so that you
see the line going through the hotel you
can choose if you want to say on the
California side the Nevada side I love
that imagery is so beautiful because
you're always toying the line and in
this at the very end there's a character
who has been struggling with himself
joining the line of good and evil and a
crucial point he ends up on the line at
the hotel and it's just so well done and
it sounds kind of like it's just gonna
hit you over the head with this symbolic
gesture but it's so gorgeous
but like I'd I was crying if this film
was so good I'm very excited right now
is this how you guys feel about film all
the time is this why you watch movies
okay the trailer very much alluded to
people really being in it heavily and
then and then those people are not in it
heavily in some aspects and that's such
a cool thing when like the trailer shows
you in hereditary I thought the little
girl I was like there's no way that she
died spoilers sorry if you haven't seen
hereditary the little girl died it's
pretty early on and I was like no
there's no fucking way that this little
girl died right now she's all over the
trailer she's the lead of the movie no
way and I love that that use of trailer
that like trailers are such a work of
art in their own selves now like it's
such a big deal it pumps you up and it
usually it just gives a lot away and if
you can do it in a way that really
intrigues you like this one did I
thought it's one of the best of trailers
I've seen in a very long time if you can
do that while not giving everything away
or while taking the audience in a
completely different direction than
would I thought they were getting into
that's so cool you want to know the most
nitpicky thing I could ever think of
it's two times in the film there was
kind of something loud happening and
somebody would say something really
quietly and then somebody over on the
other side of the room would hear it and
I'm like there's no way they heard that
loud stuff happening this one girl's
swinging on a chandelier and she asks
this guy what his name is any like
whispers it like this she's like oh it's
great to meet you
I was like there's no way that she heard
him say oh there's
really no way that's the only completely
Jim O'Hara was in this it also Nick
Offerman's in this that's like a little
Parks and Rec reunion my perfect film
anything with parson reg it's just so
weird in our Dana age social media make
is so crazy but like I like I guess I
always imagined that if there's a movie
that's really good I'm gonna hear about
it because I'm like kind of in that
world or like at least I'm on Twitter
and I follow a bunch of movie reviewers
and like you know what I mean like I
feel like I should have heard way more
about this movie let me know if you guys
feel as dramatically as I thought about
this film I am so interested if this was
just like a weird
Tamra itch that it just really gotten
scratched because I loved it I thought
it was so so good sometimes I fall into
the pit of liking films that are a
little pretentious maybe because I
didn't grow up with film so I see
something for the first time it's really
hard see or something and I'm like what
you can do this with film and everyone's
like no Tamra calm down that's it's been
done as artsy and it's just no one likes
that kind of I fell into that with
mother I really loved it
and everyone was like gross oh my god so
pretentious I'm wondering if this is
that kind of deal but I don't think so I
think it was absolutely beautiful I
really loved cabin in the woods same guy
that directed that he wrote and directed
this thank you so much for watching
everyone I will see you next week
[Music]